les fêter tout est possible tout est
permis que vous adoptiez le style
romantique exotiques ou folklorique une
seule devise à retenir osé on allie
délibérément le sport et l'habiller le
style safari à la jupe afro le cuir à la
dentelle
je trouve
non
chantal thomass racontez nous la mode
d'hésiter vient peut-être t il y aura
beaucoup de pantalons
des pantalons sarouels qui sont des
pantalons très large à françois applis
dans le haut et resserré en marre des
corsaires
des pantalons larges
beaucoup de jupes très volonté qui
s'arrête au genou les formes sont assez
simples tout devient cours le pantalons
raccourcis l'art battre aussi mais
toutes les longueurs à course la femme
doit s'habiller selon son envie ce nom
sont sa manière de travailler de vivre
à vendre cet été vivre au grand large en
costume petit marin si possible col
bateau imprimés aquatique corsair et
pompon
à la ville comme à la plage robe
parasols survêtement côte d'azur